-President Trump
has ordered the Pentagon
to plan a military parade
while his administration takes
a harsher stance on immigration
and insults DREAMers.
For more on this,
it is time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The GOP tax plan will add
$1.5 trillion to the deficit,
and now Republicans are talking
about slashing
safety net programs
to make up for it.
So, of course, President Trump
wants to throw a bunch of time
and money at an active theater
that nobody wants --
a military parade.
-Looks as if President Trump
will get the military parade
he wants in Washington.
-President Trump's vision
of soldiers marching
and tanks rolling down
the boulevards of Washington
is moving closer to reality,
and the Pentagon and White House
where officials say they have
begun to plan
a grand military parade.
-The marching orders
were this -- I want a parade
like the one in France,"
said a military official
who spoke on condition
of anonymity.
Because the planning discussions
are supposed to remain
confidential,
this is being worked at
the highest levels
of the military.
-That's right.
Trump wants a military parade,
so you're just going
full dictator now.
Just "dic" wasn't enough.
[ Laughter ]
If you are worried a tank
won't fit
on Pennsylvania Avenue,
don't worry.
If it is anything like
Trump's last parade,
there will be plenty of room.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
So a rogue state is developing
nuclear weapons.
Russia is meddling
in our elections.
The Pentagon just warned that
climate change poses a threat
to half of
all our military sites,
and you have top generals
working on a parade.
Man, you a chance to be in
the military, and you dodged it.
If you want to hold a parade
for something
you yourself actively avoided,
why not throw an IRS parade
or a parade of personal
trainers?
[ Laughter ]
What's next?
Are you going to make
the Chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
plan your prom?
But be careful if you do,
because if it goes
by popular vote,
you're not going to be happy
with who they choose
for King and Queen.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If it's popular vote.
On top of the fact that it would
be a waste of time and money,
there's also the fact
that the Pentagon itself
doesn't even seem to want it,
because Trump also asked
for a military parade
for his inauguration
and the Pentagon
didn't seem too psyched.
A Pentagon official wrote
in an internal e-mail
at the time that the Trump team
"is seriously considering
adding military vehicles
to the inaugural parade."
Later in response to an e-mail
confirming that the Trump team
abandon its efforts, the
official wrote, "Great news."
The Pentagon reacts to Trump the
same way you react to a friend
who cancels a dinner
you didn't want to go to.
"Brad says he can't make it
because he has a kidney stone.
Oh, my God, that's great news."
So, where exactly would
this parade happen?
Well, "The Washington Post"
reported that the route
would pass by a location
close to Trump's heart,
or rather, his wallet.
Trump has said he would
like it to proceed
along Pennsylvania Avenue.
It would be the same route
as Trump's inaugural parade
and pass by
his family's showpiece,
Trump International Hotel.
I has always hoped
if the military was surrounding
Trump Hotel, there would be
a general with a bull horn
saying, "Come out,
Mr. President!
The game is up!"
[ As Trump ]
I'm only a Mexican maid,
and I'm sorry to say he is
not here. Gracias, go away.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] While he is
busy planning a military parade,
Trump is supposed to be
working out a deal
with congress on immigration.
Now, Trump claims he wants
to strike a deal,
but his plan calls
for massive cuts
to family-based immigration
in return for protections
for DREAMers,
young undocumented immigrants
brought here as children.
Yesterday, Trump insisted,
without evidence,
that our immigration laws
are much looser
than other countries
and claimed that he could give
specific examples
of the countries
he was referring to.
-The world is laughing at us
because they can't believe
these policies.
They don't have it.
I could name 15 of them
right now.
-No, you couldn't.
[ Laughter ]
-You couldn't name
15 countries period.
[ As Trump ]
There's the U.S., Canada,
America, China,
China-Da, the USA,
Mexico, Chinatown.
I want to say Australia,
but it turns out Danny McBride
just made that up for a movie.
It's not a real place.
[ Normal voice ] In fact,
even if you gave Trump
the name of a country,
he couldn't say that country.
Like say Namibia.
-Nambia.
[ Laughter ]
-Tanzania.
-Tan-zany-a.
[ Laughter ]
-Or the United States.
-The United Shates.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Shates.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Republicans and Democrats
both say there's a deal
to be made
that would protect DREAMers
while giving Trump
money for his wall,
but Trump wants more than that.
His immigration framework calls
for a massive restructuring
of family-based immigration,
although doesn't call it
family-based immigration.
He opts as usual for
a much more offensive term.
-We must replace our current
system of extended family
chain migration
with a merit-based system.
Legislation that would end
chain migration
and switch our country
to a merit-based
immigration system.
-It has to be a bill
to end chain migration.
-Stop calling it
chain migration.
You're talking about families.
Don't make it sound like
there's a new Applebee's
too close to the old Applebee's.
Chain migration
is an insulting way
to refer to families
staying together.
When you hang around
with your family,
nobody calls it chain mutation.
[ Laughter ]
Look at them, they look like
the three middle figures
from the evolution of man.
[ Laughter ]
-Trump has proposed
a radical shift
that would cut legal immigration
by 44% annually
which Democrats and even
many Republicans oppose.
Now, it won't surprise you
to learn that Trump has no idea
how our current immigration laws
actually work,
but apparently neither does
his staff.
His Director
of Legislative Affairs
Marc Short was
on "Face the Nation" recently
and tried to justify Trump's use
of the phrase "chain migration"
by saying this.
-What's happening right now
in our visa system
is you're providing visas
for aunts and uncles
and siblings
that continue to go on.
Hence it's called
chain migration.
-Sounds good,
there's just one problem --
Aunts and uncles
can't be sponsored
for family-based green cards
under current law.
Oh, my God,
do you guys have any idea
what you're doing over there?
I bet the White House
is like a CVS after midnight.
[ Laughter ]
"Excuse me,
where's the toothpaste?"
"Uh? Unh-unh-unh."
"How about the deodorant?"
"Unh-uhh-unh."
"Do you want me to leave?"
"Uh-huh."
[ Laughter ]
And on top of that,
there are already limits
on the number of visas issued
per year per family category.
For some relatives,
the wait period for a visa
is over 13 years, but even
longer for some countries
with heavy demand.
Siblings in the Philippines
have to wait at least 23 years
for a visa,
and Mexican siblings,
at least 20 years.
20 years!
Can you imagine
what would happen
to a child who was unsupervised
for 20 years?
Oh, right, right,
oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Right. Yep.
Now, in return
for those massive cuts
to legal immigration,
Trump has proposed protecting
about 1.8 million DREAMers,
including some
who did not originally
sign up for the DACA program.
Now, many of them might not have
signed up because of fear,
cost, or because they weren't
sure if they were eligible.
But on Tuesday,
Trump's Chief of Staff
John Kelly offered a different,
more insulting explanation.
-There are 690,000 official
DACA registrants,
and the President sent over
what amounts to be
two and a half times that
number, to 1.8 million.
The difference between
690,000 and 1.8 million
were the people that
some would say were too afraid
to sign up,
others would say were too lazy
to get off their asses,
but they didn't sign up.
-They were too lazy?
You work for a guy who watches
eight hours of TV a day,
tweets until noon,
eats cheeseburgers in bed,
can't read a piece of paper
unless it has pictures
with his name on it, won't walk
down a flight of stairs,
and his preferred mode of
transportation is a golf cart.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is so lazy,
I wouldn't be surprised
if he had one of those grabbers
so he could reach his Diet Coke
without getting off the couch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now Trump keeps pretending
he wants merit-based immigration
when he's already made clear
many times what he really wants,
an immigration system
that takes in more white people
from countries like Norway
and fewer people
from what he infamously called
[bleep]hole countries
like those in Africa.
Obviously those comments have
prompted accusations of racism,
but don't worry --
Trump's son Don Jr.
came charging to his defense
this week claiming his father
can't be racist
because he knows rappers.
-It's been terrible to watch,
because I know him.
I've seen him my whole life.
I have seen the things
he has done.
It is amazing,
all of the rappers,
all of the this,
all his African-American friends
from Jesse Jackson
to Al Sharpton.
You know, I have pictures
with them, my whole life.
We say, "Hi,"
always been friends.
It was only till he got into
politics that, all of a sudden,
"Oh, he's the most terrible
human being in the world."
-If someone mentions
black people,
and the first thing
you think of is rappers,
you're probably racist.
[ Laughter ]
That's like saying, "Women?
Women, sure,
I know lots of secretaries."
[ Laughter ]
But that's right,
Trump can't be a racist
because he knows rappers.
He even has a rap name.
[ Laughter ]
So you got a White House that's
splitting its time
between planning
military parades,
lying about immigration,
and insulting DREAMers,
and yet according to polls,
Republicans seem
more enthusiastic about Trump
than ever.
A new poll this week found that
while Trump's overall approval
rating is just 40%,
his approval rating among
Republicans has soared to 90%.
And that illustrates a key point
about our current politics,
which is that Donald Trump
is very much
the president Republicans want.
He's not an outlier.
He's the culmination
of the modern GOP.
Trump is massively
and historically unpopular
in general,
but among Republicans,
he is exactly what they want
in a president of --
-The United Shates.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]